[Music]
thank you so much for being here and I'm
like a lot of us an insane Game of
Thrones fan to the point of madness but
I wanted to start by trying to put you
at ease because I've heard you really
you really don't like doing talk shows
it makes me very nervous is that right
I'm terrified right now you're terrified
well I'm terrified look at us were
idiots he's sitting right there does
that put you at ease at all
I'm I'm a little shy you're little shy
thank you I'm also a little nervous to
be seated next to the House of Lannister
he's a raw sensuality that's just
emanating it's too much it's too much
sensually I had trouble sitting next to
him please let's just try and get this
thing back on course if we can Lena as I
said I'm a huge Game of Thrones fan and
like a lot of people the episode last
Sunday made my eyes melt out of my head
it was so intense everyone's talking
about it have you spoken to your cast
mates because there's a lot of cast
mates that will no longer be reporting
to work a lot of them and I don't want
to spoiler alert you know but a lot of
intense stuff goes down in the last
episode and have you talked to your
friends did they see this coming I rang
Richard who plays Rob straight after and
he said he hasn't watched it because
he's so upset to be leaving yeah and
then I spoke to Michelle fatty who said
weirdly she was in the doctors with a
throat infection really as if the loss
of her character has now made her sick
kind of mimicking life and I'm looking
life yeah I think a throat infection
doesn't come close to what happened
that's right I'm sorry I forgot I mean
no no it's it was so intense and I'm
curious does this make you worry I mean
this is such a terrific show but one of
the things that makes it so terrific is
that anybody can go at any time does
this make you live in mortal fear I mean
have you read the books do you know what
happens to your character have you read
ahead I know I'm still living but I
admitted while sitting next to George
that I hadn't read the books and now I
fear for my life oh really he may become
angry now that you haven't read his
books and you'll be hit by a car which
is very that hasn't happened much in
that realm a cab is gonna hit you fans
are not shy about their really intense
feelings about your character Queen
Cersei they she is she is tough I find
some redeeming qualities in her myself
but but she the fans can some of them
really hate her and they let you know
that don't they yes yes they're not I
mean I guess as a compliment you know it
is when you're buying a table and
someone's like you know [ __ ] about
tonight's show
I blame Offerman I really do he did this
it's a compliment people really do but
people get that mad at you yes all
people say I love her and I kind of
worry more for them she's everything I
am in secret yeah I would think there is
some protection cuz it is a compliment
they love the character that you're
playing when I go to a restaurant and
someone's like I hate that Conan guy to
me it's me oh I know what a character
what is it must be difficult you have to
wear I mean everyone has to be in full
costume for this but I've heard that you
wear an extremely restrictive corset for
this show is that right yes they lock
you in and then on top of that they put
belts and you know that kind of 5in it's
not fun because you just want to eat
breakfast
that's me before every show they put me
into Spanx various girdles and trusses
to hold me in and then what happens
you're wearing that all day you can't
get out of it you can't get out of it
it's good it kind of makes you angry so
I channel that associ and then when they
take it off it's heaven oh that works
it's like it's amazing because you felt
this way all day and then they suddenly
they release it it goes and then the
relief yes so that was a wig by the way
yes why are you wearing a helmet